the starting block below is two units
long use the tools to the right to
convert the starting block into both of
the gold blocks that are 5 8 units long
and 1-3 4 units long you can see your
progress as the current block so what
are they telling us to do so this is the
starting block right over here they're
telling us this is two units long so a
unit must be about this long right here
about half of this starting block
and we have these tools on the right and
my first goal block right over here in
blue they say that that's 5 8 and that
makes sense because if this is about a
hole then that looks like about 5 8 this
right over here would be about 8 8. so
this looks about 5 8 and then they tell
us that this other one that's below my
screen right over here is one and
three-fourths so they tell us that this
is one and three-fourths units long one
and three-fourths is also the same thing
as seven fourths so i somehow need to
let's see what are my tools what are the
tools available to me well i can cut my
starting block into a certain number of
pieces and then i'm going to copy that
starting block
over here for block one and i'm going to
try to match it this goal block and then
i'm also going to copy it for block 2 to
match that second gold block so i'm
going to try to get some i'm going to
try to get something that's 5 8 and i'm
also going to try to get something
that's one and three-fourths now 3 4 is
the same thing as 6 8. and the reason
why i care about eights is eights is a
smaller unit so it should be able to if
i can convert the starting block into
eighths
then i can copy it enough time to get
exactly the 5 8 and exactly the 1 and 3
4 which is the same thing as 3 4 is the
exact same thing as 6 8. so let's get
our starting block into eighths
so if we're starting with if we're
starting with
two holes or we're starting with two
units long
so if i cut it once now this is a whole
unit now if i cut a hole now if i cut it
twice and so now if i cut it four times
so i've cut my original block into four
times so now this is this right over
here is half a unit
and actually if i want to convert cut it
into eights i need to cut it 16 times so
let me do that
15 16. so i cut two units
into 16 equal pieces or i guess this is
1 16 of 2 so that is going to be an
eighth and now i just have to multiply
this the appropriate number of times
this right over here is 5 8 this is 1 8.
so let me
copy this one two three four five so
that is five eighths and then here i
need to do one and three fourths
remember one and three fourths is the
same thing as seven fourths it's four
fourths plus three fourths which is
seven fourths seven fourths is the same
thing as fourteen eighths so this right
over here is one eighth i just need to
make fourteen of these two three four
five six seven eight actually let me
show what i'm doing
9 10 11 12 13 14 and there we go it's
exactly the same length as gold block 2.
this is 14 8 14 8 is the exact same
length as this 14 8 is the same thing as
7 4 which is the same thing as 1 3 4.
this is 5
this is 5 8 which is the same thing as 5
8 so let's check our answer and we got
it right